[Music]
what up guys
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
and it's the two daddies and a baby
edition once again
yo i think we would kill it as daddy's
if the baby came this size yeah if if
this fool was our baby
yeah so basically i just do my own [ __ ]
and you guys are going to live alone
wouldn't you want us as dads
i feel like bart's already kind of like
my dad you'll be like hey right can i
stay out for three months straight i'm
like yeah
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go to bed you're like or we
could go outside and shoot guns
yeah oh dude that'll be cool man yeah
that would be a perfect family
i mean that's already what we do it's no
different when me and the dean live
together back in alhambra yeah we had
this pellet gun
and we would line up like bottles yeah
yeah even shoot our grill sometimes
just [ __ ] or even shoot would hide in
the corner of the living room yeah and
shoot through her open like it was only
like a sliver this big
of our door because of the angle we're
at all the way down the street to a stop
and we'll be shooting the stop sign from
like like a mile away
what the [ __ ] with the bb gun yeah it
was so [ __ ] you guys are such
rednecks dude it's so funny it's so
[ __ ] loud that it'll be like
bing and then we're like
[Laughter]
it was funny because then like it was
after fourth of july the first time holy
[ __ ]
i think we have a vlog on it online and
then casey would always bring his like
you guys don't drink i don't drink
casey's beers
uh so we would have like a hell of left
over there's always those new castle
beers that we had on the
on the porch that were just exploding
but those are like we
i don't know like jill came on was like
what the [ __ ] are you we were shooting
full
cans or full bottles of beer and i think
one of them we're also like i wonder how
many bottles they can go through
so i think we lined up like seven of
them yeah yeah i think it went through
like four of them or something whoa it
was a pelican
we're so dumb we're like shaking them up
too and everything i got a really sick
ass pellet gun like mine is like
really legit the sniper one you got to
use a bike pump to pump it each time
yeah it's not like one of these dudes oh
so that's not like a legit
hunting one then yeah i'll [ __ ] show
you man i got it right here
what is it for like rodents and stuff
yeah it's for pheasant or
anything uh it's pretty legit
that's like my brother he's like super
intellectic for like end of the world
survival stuff
but he has a pellet gun for end of the
world uh he's like get a pellet gun and
get like a little one of those like
foldable 22s
he's like if you and just in case you
don't want to make too much noise and
you
still need to catch like food you know
that's true i never thought about like
that
oh damn that's a scary look that thing
looks
like a [ __ ] like a real good that
looks like the [ __ ] sniper from halo
dude this [ __ ] wasn't cheap man it was
pretty pricey
if you brought that out uh people that
don't know about guns but that's an
assault rifle
yeah that's cause we had our canadian
friends that came over and they looked
at it they're like
is that a is that a real gun it's just
like americans just have guns everywhere
that's literally what they thought and
i'm like no it's just an air rifle
a borderline toy it is a toy but it's a
it's a way where we can okay because i
got it so like when we go
out and then uh we just want to catch
like small
like game yeah we can you know like get
it
and then and then technically it won't
be illegal
because you know how some places you
can't use a gun at all of course
but you can use a bow and arrow or
whatever that's true we can use this
oh tight yeah but it's strong dude you
know how many feet per second the
pellets go through oh [ __ ] i
did when i bought it but it was pretty
powerful
you could probably look it up just look
up the it looks [ __ ] legit though
oh it's well it's 3 000 psi pressure
oh [ __ ] that sounds [ __ ] stupid and
it is a 22.
oh so it's a big pellet yeah it's so
funny like
when you're talking about your canadian
friends just seeing that out like like
for us we're so
used to that thing right but we also
know how to handle it safely
like growing up like in the high school
i went to like even junior high
like we had a lot of like all my it's
where like my city was like so
not like it was super multi-cultural but
also in terms of like
um economics and all that stuff but we
had kids from
all different like rich people poor kids
poor people we all just got along
but we would have like some more homies
that were just kicking with us so like
drop their back and then a [ __ ] like
full like
handgun or like uh like one of those
like mac tens will pop out and you're
just like
and back then i don't know [ __ ] so i'm
like [ __ ] freaking out cause they're
gang members yeah a lot of them weren't
do you remember the first time you guys
saw a gun i grew up with guns and stuff
so like it was because when i i think
the first time i saw a handgun
um i was 14 and i remember this is
like during gang life we were gonna do a
home inva
invasion for the first time and it was
like you know you
don't want to look like a [ __ ] with all
your friends right and then you have
friends that are way more experienced
than you
and then i remember one of the homies
was like okay i gotta go home and get my
strap first
i'm like yeah go get that [ __ ] you're
like oh no there's a gun
we went to his house and then he hid it
in his towel rack and he pulled his
towel out
and then when he opened it and i was
like i was pretending like i seen it
before too i'm like oh yeah yep that's a
strap-on
and then i remember he he brought it
over and he was trying to hold it
and then i my hand when it was reaching
it was like
shaking so bad that i knew i probably
would have dropped it and it probably
would have fired a bullet i'm not
i'm comfortable yeah but i remember
being scared as
[ __ ] the first time i ever saw him
that's that's why i'm like with all my
friends that
like they know that we do it safely
properly we're not into that gang life
it's just like
sport protection whatever you want to
call it i at least want them to know how
to handle it properly and safely so
they're not
afraid of it just in case they ever do
come across it or they need to fight
someone that does have it and know how
to like
disarm them uh because there are a lot
of people that
literally would get like just they'll
freaking just see and you're scared like
oh my god
dang no my yeah same with me like like
kind of like similar to you
like i had a lot of um friends
and their dads like had just guns in the
garage that they were working on
they went camping they took us and then
they taught us how to shoot and all that
so my introduction as a kid was way
like it's a tool like it's they use it
for hunting so you never had the scary
face
no i actually liked it but my immediate
family like my parents were against it
not really against it but they're like
you know guns are illegal in japan and
they're not really um
outdoorsy like we did a lot of fishing
but then
um my dad wasn't really like into that
stuff
so uh they're like yeah you you know you
could get gun toys but we're not gonna
get you like a
air rifle and all these things but all
of my friends actually had air rifles
because like that was like the
progression right like when you're in
elementary school
uh you learn with the air rifle and then
they teach you those basics with that
and then they give you like a 22 or
something like that i think that's the
best way because you also get bored of
it
and you know how to do it properly so
it's nothing to you so like uh some of
my family is like super baller
and i remember i think i told you the
story before where it's like my little
cousin uh so we go to their house and
he's like
oh my dad just got a new car come see it
come see and he's so excited show us
so we go in and there was a like a 911
in the car and then uh
with a brand new panomaru [ __ ] sick
and he's like
we're like [ __ ] freaking out and he's
like no no it's out back and we're like
oh [ __ ] something crazier
it goes like just a honda civic but for
him it's just something new
he doesn't get it right so he's like
this is old like this is like
we've had this [ __ ] you know there's
that one like uh arabic kid i think you
showed me he was so excited about his
ford mustang that he bought
oh yeah yeah he already had like i think
lambo is one of those dubai kids
he already has hella lambos and ferraris
but he was vlogging and he goes you're
not gonna believe it it's the 20 like
2010
ford mustang i'm like what the [ __ ] i
kind of get it
because so like my my jag right now
is like three times the price of what i
got the
the land cruiser oh yeah yeah but the
land cruiser was just such
a crazier experience yeah even though
like dollar value wise it's
cheaper it's also one of a kind it's
hard to find something in that condition
yeah
for sure and the price that i got and
just everything so
and and i've been searching for like six
months whereas like
any new car you can just go into the lot
and if you can afford it you can get it
yeah
unless it's like a limited edition or
something special yeah
yeah i think that's the feeling maybe
but they also don't know like
if they if you don't know the cars and
it's like something new it just feels
bigger better yeah like when i look at
ferraris and like porsches and lambos
and stuff like that
like they look super nice and they're
tight but it doesn't
um like wow me the way like your land
cruiser does or like seeing like my
favorite
classic car like when i see those guys
it's like
it's like finding a 70 year old grandma
with the body of a 20 year old whoa how
did that happen
yo you know what's crazy is i'm starting
to realize that a lot of people actually
don't understand um car pricing
and like just in general like how to
make something
dope out of old yeah like a lot of
people just buy like new cars like they
go to the
lot and then they get something new or
like it's just more convenient yeah
and then when they hear the price of
like how like what i got it for and all
this stuff they're just like wait what
like it blows their mind like they
thought it was more or less more
well and also uh when you
you know like just get something that's
classic or or you just kind of
spend a little bit of like time and love
into the car
it looks rare and expensive yeah even
though it might be like
cheaper than a a new accord or something
yeah yeah yeah
and then so i think that's what maybe a
lot of people don't know
but also like they don't you don't get
all the like modern
cool [ __ ] either so like they might not
like that is there something in your
land cruiser that you're like
man i wish i had this that your jaguar
does yeah i think i got really used to
bluetooth yeah that's one thing can't
you just get like a radio
and then it'll be yeah pretty much the
same yeah yeah
and then the handling is just different
because it's like
more meant for like off-road i guess
yeah like it's just high you know it
can't it can't it's not a highway
vehicle so yeah yeah that's the
difference struggling to do like 70.
so yeah that's tight but it's supposed
to make you
got a stain can you see that
you have a stand on a shirt yeah
i wish i had something for it this video
was brought to you by
oxiclean max force one speaking of
stains
during the quarantine i was in a room
for 10 days so i've been getting stains
all over the place not
the naughty stains that you guys are
talking are thinking about
but um i finally was getting in a
creative face
so i was just gonna draw like random
[ __ ] and i don't know why but i think
like you know when you're just kind of
like sick and like
sticky and sweaty nasty and nasty and
your palms are all sweaty
my dumb ass opened a marker and when i
opened the marker
the marker just flew out of my hand and
landed on my sheet
why did you open a marker cause i was
gonna start drawing some [ __ ]
oh you mean like like the cap i thought
you were just trying to dissect oh no no
no no no no yeah just by me
i have this [ __ ] but by me opening it my
[ __ ] butterfingers
let go of it it landed on my duvet
check out the vlog and i was like oh
[ __ ] those are
the we bought that to sell the house so
once again
oxyclean max force came in clutch and i
was able to put it in and i used my
toothbrush
to scrub it in and then it got it out if
you guys still don't know what it
is it is a convenient laundry stain
remover spray that tackles the toughest
dried in stains with five types of stain
fighters to remove grease
oil grass blood soil clay food and drink
stains
the first time it dissolves in traps
grease and oil
lifts food stains from fabrics binds to
dirt
and soil to suspend them and rinse them
away it's safe on colors
spray now wash up to seven days later
you've got to try oxyclean max force for
yourself
to work your magic with oxiclean go to
oxiclean.com
maxforce1 to get a coupon for one dollar
off
and you can be like bart here and save
his duvet
or if you're not any bust all over the
place probably get all that stuff out
too
it's funny that all these things happen
in this last vlog
it's all within one vlog dude that is
crazy is that the
panel's in the same vlog too yeah you
are destructive man
dude i have one more thing that jio
doesn't know about
but i'm just gonna fix it before i tell
her
you are destructive day i think on day
five or six on the cdc it says if you
test
a negative you can get come out of
quarantine
because that's past the day so day five
or day six
i took a at home test first it said
negative
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah so now i'm gonna
go into urgent care and get a real test
i go to our [ __ ] shutters thing i
i open the window because i don't want
to go through the house i open the
the window at the minute i put my hand
on the windowsill
it popped the entire bottom frame oh
[ __ ] the [ __ ] and i'm like
oh wait you were going to climb out of
the window i did i ended up climbing out
the window but when i got to urgent care
i tested negative i mean positive so
instead of walking through the house to
be safe
you were gonna walk out of the window
and then take the
and i did yeah it's safer for the family
it's safer for the family yeah yeah yeah
so so wait yeah but when i put my hand
on the
frame of the shutter yeah it popped it
off oh [ __ ]
and i try to put it back on and i can't
so now i gotta go buy super glue
before glc before you sell the house too
oh [ __ ] i know yo you know what i've
been getting into
is like um car like
fixing videos and just house fixing and
then it's like
i always pay people or like i would
usually be the one like bar like
breaking things
yeah and i'm just like [ __ ] i don't want
to deal with that [ __ ] but now it's the
opposite
like i'm really just starting to fix
[ __ ] here and there i ordered some parts
for my land cruiser and i think it's all
because of that
like moving into my own small little
space that i'm controlling
making it beautiful and then like you
know you want to maintain some something
dope you start fixing it yeah but i
don't know i never had that in my
personality before
it becomes fun making things into
projects and stuff yeah
but also i think it's because i didn't
have this kind of time uh
so before i was like ah [ __ ] somebody
[ __ ] fix it for me
that's hot because that's how i'm with
like the guns too i'm like somebody
clean it for me i bought yeah i buy like
all the parts
and i go here ryan
just take it and i get it back and it's
all like all the parts are on there like
yes
and then you feel like a real man you're
like i bought this
does it does not make you feel good to
do it yourself it does it really does
but i think it's a time thing like joe
was saying like because i mean
coming out of the military you know how
to do everything right like the you can
take it apart completely
you know how to zero it and all that
stuff i don't know how to do any of that
[ __ ] anymore yeah
so now i'm like someone help me help
i think from like growing up in all the
experiences i had like staying with my
dad having like a furniture store like i
know how to move furniture rugs
how to build things how this one knows
all kinds of techniques from moving
furniture
yeah it's like so easy and i see people
trying to move like a couch just trying
to put like a couch that's like
this through a door that's this i'm just
trying to shove it i'm like it literally
doesn't fit why don't you turn it
yeah but it's common knowledge like one
of the things you taught me was uh we
had a giant area rug
and then you know once it gets on the
floor it kind of like pushes all the air
out yeah and there's like it turns into
a vacuum
so you you can't even move it it sucks
on the ground what he taught me is you
just put air underneath and as it has
the waves
that's when you just slowly move it and
i'm like what the [ __ ] floats and glides
it's genius yeah i don't even know but
now like all my friends like
i know how to build stuff i know how to
do stuff not like nelson or like ryan
and all these guys but like
simple things or even like cooking like
it's so much fun but i feel
like more human
almost in a sense where it's like doing
things by yourself compared to just
clicking like postmates or
calling this company to come do things
it actually feels like satisfying feel
connected to it
yeah you do appreciate it more
definitely like hand washing my car
i haven't done that i haven't hand
washed a car in
years man me too i don't even know what
that's like and then
after doing it and then i'm just like
when did you do it
to the land cruiser yeah and then also
the after
you know like polishing doing all the
extra stuff putting tire shine all that
extra yeah yeah
it's it's um it's weird it's therapeutic
it is yeah i'm so stupid with those
things because i'm like
i feel like i'm not the income level to
spend money on like
getting my whole car detailed and things
but i'll spend 40 dollars twice a day on
postmates
twice a day that's a detailing you could
do that yeah you could do it for 40
bucks
what are you what are you getting for 40
dollars but it's just like with delivery
costs and all those things that adds up
that's true each meal i remember i i got
chicken and waffles
and by that time it got delivered it was
like about 40 bucks for that one meal
yeah and it should be like 12 bucks at
the actual spot
yeah so just like uh i usually get aunt
like i piggyback off of ants order so if
they order food i'll just be like yeah
get me a bowl or whatever yeah when you
just order that one thing
like one time i was just really feeding
boba i think it ended up paying like 18
for the boba yeah because you have the
boba then you got the
uh tax then you got the tip and then you
got the delivery fee
but it helps so much it makes life so
much easier like
because otherwise i wouldn't go to the
store stores are closed and everything
so it just made life like
10 times easier to have that applicable
yeah so it's like it's the same thing
with like paying someone to do it paying
someone to build something yeah
it's like it is your time that's worth
it to do it or save some money
or just get it like delivered get
someone to come and fix it and like you
could spend that time
on other things or like that stress yeah
if if i didn't look at it as money
or wasted because for example right
um i didn't like washing dishes
and i and i and i do and i don't have a
dishwasher anymore i just wash my hands
hate washing dishes
yeah but it is a good way to take a
break
while you get something done so like
your mind is occupied on doing something
and you can like listen to music so in
between like let's say
i edit a video and then it's it's
rendering or
or exporting i can use those five
minutes to just wash a
few dishes and go right back oh i see
yeah or like doing
some kind of productive mindless
activity
that's like cleaning it's like a mental
break yeah yeah and i was and i so if
you use it as a way to doing that
or like to take a break but you're
actually working that's pretty cool
yeah i didn't notice it so like even
from fixing my car and
i used to look at it as like oh it's i
gotta fix this
you know like a chore and then you start
working on it and you're like you know
what this is a nice way to just go
outside
and feel the sun and move your body it's
cool because like
especially like with all those things
that you're saying i just add music to
it
and it's like the only time i can really
just focus yeah otherwise my mind is
racing
about so many different things but like
see i'm just i love cleaning my room
like vacuuming and like
putting stuff back into place because
like before i was bad with it
now it's just like a blast music i have
cool speakers uh and then it just
becomes like a fun task
that i look forward to doing especially
when you can
be like a guy that's on meth but
hella like rearranging everything every
[ __ ] five seconds
and just like hell yeah i'm gonna take a
picture of this [ __ ] right here
those guys are the most creative
you